Hello Freak bitches
in the video game industry with these people that are predominantly left wing
and predominantly progressive quote.
I say progressive,
but progressive is kind of a dirty word now.
It's becoming,
there's a difference between liberal and progressive.
Well,
it's,
it would be great if everybody was liberal.
If it'd be great if everybody was progressive and it'd be great if everybody
wanted people to have freedom of choice and,
and freedom to be whoever you want.
But that's not really what those things are anymore.
Those things are like ideologies.
There are these predetermined patterns of behavior that people subscribed to in
a very,
very rigid way.
How,
what did you find was an issue when people found out about your extreme
understanding and a respect for the history of the United States?
Well,
they think it's,
they primarily,
they think it was like kind of a joke because not,
not,
not a hydro,
but like you're,
you're a clown kind of.
Because why?
Because I believe in a small government,
for instance,
I believe in low taxation.
I believe in the elimination of the income tax and things like this.
These are,
these are Rad,
but I don't actually have like,
not all my ideas are radical or even outside of the mainstream.
Socially,
I'm probably further to the left than many of these people,
you know.
Uh,
I think that it's,
it,
it goes back to this idea,
and this is something Dave Ruben has touched on a lot in this show,
which I'm sure you're familiar with,
which is this idea that it's really all or nothing.
Like they don't want to be an ally with someone that might be able to help them
in x,
Y,
and Z if they disagree with people in a,
B and c.
So they could have had a great ally in me and being like,
I've been pro gay marriage forever.
I've been pro choice.
Uh,
you know,
uh,
um,
for the decriminalization of drugs,
I'm for the legalization of prostitution.
I'm for a lot of these things that are very far to the left socially that we
probably could find some agreement on somewhere and we can work on those things
and get those things done together.
But because I say also like,
Hey,
the income tax is predatory and really hurts people.
I own a business,
I owned a business and I want to,
I guess I want another one now.
And I know that I could have hired another person if taxes weren't so onerous on
me.
Um,
and so I also stand on there and they,
they,
they're like,
this never happened.
This stuff that you just said never happened.
This left,
this left the left wing.
Stuff that we agree on never happened because you don't believe in because you
have this one thing that we have a problem with now we're going to get.
But you're not being that clear about that.
Like what is the issue when it comes to small government,
like you wanting small government,
what's the opposition to that?
What are they saying?
Well,
they say like they make a lot of it's insinuations cause a lot of it isn't even
things that I feel or believe.
So an example would be,
um,
you know,
I see a lot of people say all the time,
like a column doesn't believe in welfare or column doesn't believe in,
in an social security.
I'm like,
I never said that actually.
I just,
I believe that these things should be reformed and,
and maybe take it back a step,
but they even look at that as a push too far on the,
on the system.
I guess what I'm trying to say to you,
and I'm sorry I'm not being more lucid with you,
I'm trying my hardest is,
is that they're,
they,
you have to agree with them lockstep,
right?
If they see you in one way that isn't it,
that is,
is injurious to their cause or to that is conflicting or contrary to what they
believe.
They do not give a fuck about anything else you believe.
And that's the thing that always frustrated me and what so surprise me within
that,
people really were running me out on a rail out of the gaming
industry with the,
with an completely innocuous joke,
which I think tells you everything you need to know about the,
the intent that they don't see.
They don't want allies in different ways.
Allies in different close allies.
They want just,
they just want complete,
you know,
it's very Orwellian.
They just want you to be completely like them.
And if you're not like them,
they don't want anything to do with you.
And it's these,
and it's not even like I was advocating for anything crazy.
I don't advocate for anything crazy.
I don't think that doesn't sound crazy at all.
But what's interesting is we've kind of turned a corner where in many ways the
right is more tolerant than the left to variations in their ideology.
Whereas the right is much more tolerant to people that support gay marriage.
The right is much more tolerant to people that,
I mean this is,
you fill in the blanks,
there's a bunch of different rights that the REIT would sort of accept from
someone who also voted Republican.
But the left isn't like if,
if you got to the point where like I got an a in a heated argument with someone
wants about abortion,
which I'm pro choice,
but what I was saying,
well essentially what I was,
it was a criticism of a Richard Dawkins quote where he's comparing a human
embryo to a pig fetus or a pig embryo.
I forget what the terms you used,
but I'm like,
well that's ridiculous because one of them is going to become a person if you
don't take it out of your body.
Right.
And that was the idea behind it.
Like you can't,
you can't use that sort of an analogy because it's not true.
I mean it's just one has the potential for being a person.
And I was being accused by this guy of being right wing because of it.
And I was like,
well,
I'm not right wing.
I'm just talking about the potential for life.
Like a pig embryo is never going to be my neighbor Mike.
You know,
it's just not,
you know what I mean?
But,
but that baby,
I'm not saying you should be forced to make that baby a person and keep it in
your body when it's a few cells and then,
uh,
two weeks old.
And then,
I'm not saying that you can't choose when to terminate your pregnancy,
but what I'm saying is you're terminating a pregnancy.
We both know what you're doing.
I'm not saying you shouldn't be able to do it,
but to pretend that it's not messy and nobody wants it to be messy.
Nobody wants it to be a complicated issue.
They want it to be cut and dry.
If you're on the left in particular,
it's pro choice,
a woman's reproductive choice,
that freedom of your body to do what you want.
I get all that.
I'm 100% with you,
but let's,
let's not lie about what it is because as soon as,
as soon as we distort the reality of what the thing is,
then we put up these ideological boundaries.
And blinders and we make communication very difficult and we make these rigid
ideologies almost like a religion.
They're,
they're almost like dogma.
And when you do,
I put it,
I mean,
when you do that,
you have real problems because people can't communicate.
So if someone,
these are the things that I,
I forgot for so long in a way,
because I was writing about games,
which I love.
I Love Games.
I think they're important.
They're an important piece of escape.
They're an important piece of art.
I think that's all great.
But being able to engage with someone like yourself,
with someone like a Dave Rubin or someone like a Steven Crowder,
whoever it might be.
I was on Glenn Beck's radio show last week.
It brings out an energy in me that wear a bow tie.
I was,
oh,
I don't know.
I was on the phone,
so I have no,
he could have been naked for on.
Uh,
but it brings out an energy me where I'm like,
I can finally engage with people that know what the fuck they're talking about
in this particular realm,
which I think is so exciting.
And so interesting and we can have,
you know,
we had,
we debated,
we don't agree on everything.
I think that's awesome.
That's a really cool that you found,
uh,
a very big positive out of this.
Now you can express yourself more honestly and you can,
you can gravitate towards your real interests and yeah,
that's what I'm trying to do.
I'm trying to use this as an opportunity for myself and try and use it as an
opportunity to just carve out a little slice of the Internet.
However big or small might be where we can affect some positive change and like
an idea,
you know,
ideas and learning and free expression and free thought and making mistakes and
disagreeing and all that.
I think that's all great.
I want to use this as an example.
I want to get away from the Orthodoxy of the gaming industry.
It's stifling and it's strangling and that's why they think,
let's go back to that because why do you think it is like that?
Why is the gaming industry so hardcore ideologically left wing progressive?
Like no variations,
no room for debate.
Why is that?
Well,
I think it's,
it's portrayed,
it's like it all gets funneled through a media that is,
that is hyper liberal.
Right?
So it's,
it's similar in a way to what's going on with the media in,
in news and politics.
These,
um,
you know,
underneath the surface of the gaming industry are,
there are plenty of conservatives and libertarians,
they,
they hide.
Yeah,
they do a lot of them.
A lot of them will,
I'm sorry,
go ahead.
I was just gonna say,
a lot of them talk to me.
I mean,
I know people that are like heads of studios that feel the way I do.
I know people that are in the trenches at Qa and doing like very menial things
that gaming studios,
I feel the way I do and everything in between.
I remember at GDC game developer conference in San Francisco,
which happens every spring,
six or seven years ago,
a guy pulled me aside.
This is the first time it ever happened to me.
And this was when I was kind of starting to make a name for myself and he pulled
me aside and he's like,
hey man,
I work at x,
Y,
and Z and it works on a big game.
And he's like,
keep doing what you're doing.
There are a lot of people out there that agree with what you're saying.
Um,
but they're,
they're,
they,
they don't dare speak out because they'll get lambasted in some way.
Look what happened to me over something so innocuous there.
Obviously you were saying that there is some pushback about your ideas before
this.
Yes.
What,
what did you experience?
Well,
so every time I would write a politically driven,
um,
op Ed for instance,
when I was at ign,
I had,
I was,
I was senior editor,
but I kind of had like editor at large qualities where it meaning for B,
Let,
don't know,
editor at large,
basically in a way,
do whatever they want.
Like they'll find something to write about.
I used to go away for days at a time and no research things and then write these
big 50,000 word articles,
um,
50,000 words.
Yeah.
The history of not that kind of time,
dude.
Well,
I,
I did,
I carved it out,
but what about people reading it?
Oh No,
it was in five parts.
The history of naughty dog.
It was like my opus naughty dog's this very huge actually in Santa Monica.
Very huge game developer,
very talented game developer.
I went and talked at 19 people,
got about a bunch of primary sources and,
and all these things.
And this piece that I really cared about.
Um,
and so,
but when I would write things like the political correctness piece about,
let me give you an example.
There's a game that was canceled,
um,
maybe five years ago or so.
It was pretty late in development.
So it's weird to cancel a game when they've already spent a bunch of money on
it.
It was called six days in Fallujah and it was a game about it.
It was a third person shooter.
I think about,
uh,
the experience of Fallujah in Iraq.
You know,
terrible conflict that,
that happened there.
And people even on the right were getting upset about being like,
it's too soon.
It's,
it's uh,
this is,
this is still ongoing.
How can you do?
And I wrote a piece being like,
what are you all saying?
Like this is awesome,
this is so great that someone wants to tell a story like this and,
and,
and do something like this.
And you just get it from all sides.
People will be like,
you know,
it's,
it's not sensitive.
It's,
it's,
it's all of these kinds of things.
And then the girlfriend mode thing I wrote about where people were like,
oh,
you're a sexist and blah,
blah,
blah.
And I'm like,
I'm actually just protecting the sanctity of a man who might've made a mistake.
That's it.
You know,
instead of destroying him,
it goes back to this whole thing of like the last year,
I'm sorry,
the girlfriend mode,
the borderlands story I told you where the guy,
and they were all going after him and going after his job and doing all these
things.
And I wrote a piece being like,
hey,
yeah,
like if this is a far skies,
like he made a mistake maybe and I don't know that he shows a soft target and
they just went after it.
Exactly.
And uh,
it reminded,
so you've experienced blowback?
Yeah.
Every time.
What was the blow back from that,
from you defending this guy saying,
well,
he just really fucked up the way he described things,
but he was,
it was an innocent in that regard.
Well,
you lose like social cache when every time it's something like this would
happen.
Right.
So that's why I say like this was the moment,
the joke was the moment that they were looking to pounce.
Really.
And I'm not saying that they were calculating,
everyone's waiting,
but they saw an opportunity and they took it because over time you lose respect
over people because of your political stances.
He completely reasonable political stances,
I think where they remember that you said this and he said this and he said this
and said,
listen,
like really?
You didn't,
weren't really having debates with people where you were disagreeing with them.
It was simply a matter of reaction to some of the things that you had written
when they were trying to box you into some sort of a conservative group.
Right.
And they would call me in and you know,
now it's like I'm a Nazi,
I'm all right.
I'm all these things.
I'm like,
I don't think,
I don't think I have one.
Alright.
I don't even really know what the alt right means,
but like,
like what is alt right?
Like what happened to me,
it seems like the far fringe is like the Richard Spencer is of the world and Neo
Nazis and the white supremacists and the end,
the actual,
uh,
nationalists.
Well,
as soon as you write alt on something,
I feel like it's a message board thing.
Like,
all right.
It's like it's a t it's a reddit thing.
Yeah,
exactly.
So,
all right.
Alternative,
right?
Like what is it?
I mean I don't,
I don't know.
I hope not based on their,
based on their,
based on their characterization of it,
but to me,
I'm sorry,
go ahead.
No.
What is,
uh,
what,
how would they define you as being all right?
What would they say that,
that you have outright characteristics.
You can see these message boards for instance,
a lot of people were very supportive on reddit and all these kinds of places are
a little more known for free thought.
But there's this one video game,
a message board in particular,
um,
that is just insane.
And there was 125 page or so thread about me,
20 posts or I think it might even be 50 posts the page.
And I was reading it and it hurts some of it that because people are like,
first of all,
people telling me I said things I never said,
I'm like,
do you think people like Collins,
you know,
against,
his name is no taxation as even believe the taxes should exist.
I often talk about how I really like Ian Rand and I really like Atlas Shrug,
but I don't consider myself an objectivist.
I don't believe that selfishness is necessarily a virtue.
I just think she's interesting and I think some of her ideas are interesting.
You know,
God forbid I exist somewhere in the gray area,
but they're like Collins and objectivists and he's selfish and Blah Blah Blah
and like Collins a Nazi and he,
he's a racist.
He's a song.
I think the term,
a lot of the news was soft racist or soft bigot,
soft race and being like that.
He,
he doesn't,
he doesn't intentionally or actually overtly say anything but supports causes
that are racist or sexist.
These are the kind of character assassinations that were going on basically
people with on,
on,
um,
on bulletin boards with,
with yarn and maps.
Like that's what,
how I picture them,
like trying to make continuous connections and,
and,
and it's like these things aren't even things I feel and,
and things that I said or being taken out of context.
I often use the,
um,
in video games,
one of the big things is like,
you know,
there's a need for diverse casts and diverse protagonists and stuff like that.
And I often use the case that I used to use the saying,
I don't believe in diversity for diversity's sake.
I believe that an artist should tell his story.
So if an artist,
a writer and a of the game wants to have an all white cast,
and that's what he thinks serves his story,
I don't think that makes them a racist.
If he wants to have an all Asian cast,
I don't think that makes him a racist either.
I think that's what he wants to do.
Um,
and people took that out of context and we're calling me a racist and a bigot
and all of these kinds of things.
And it's,
it's,
it's hurtful because there's no one there that no one's defending me,
you know,
and I can't,
I can't defend myself because I'll just make it worse.
So it was a kind of like this hapless kind of situation that I found myself in
and I tried to make the best of it.
I had a debate once about that with a friend who was an Asian actor and he was
talking about the lack of roles for Asians in Hollywood and what a massive issue
is.
And you know,
that he wanted to raise awareness of it.
And I was like,
man,
but this,
we're talking about a creative venture.
You're talking about somebody writing a story.
Like I think the,
the correct way to go about it is to try to figure out how to get your own
project through or someone else who feels very strongly about this,
trying to get their own project through.
But the right way is not for someone to have to compromise their creative vision
in order to encompass the full spectrum of races in whatever story they're
writing.
Like it's still creative story.
Like if you want to write a story about a small town in Maine,
like Stephen King has done so often,
you shouldn't have to have 10% Asians in that story.
I mean,
you just,
that's not what creativity is about.
It's about there.
There are places and people and that what you're going to run into all black
folks or,
or are you going to run into all Norwegian people?
I mean,
and those stories are just as valid as a story that's fully Dovers you.
No,
no,
I don't think that that necessarily makes anything better.
And I also think
that when you're talking about that you're,
so you sort sir,
you're sort of talking about it like there should be a quota,
you know,
and like Hollywood should recognize the need for these people to be in films and
movies and says you,
you're,
you're making this politically correct sort of,
um,
you'll be passing these,
these judgements on this thing that is all about imagination.
I mean,
Hollywood essentially.
Like what,
when you're making a television show or you making a movie,
it's really about an imagination.
It's about imagination and vision and having that vision being entertaining for
people.
And if you like only want to write about the people that you were in college
with,
that you were,
that you shared a dorm room with,
you should be out allowed to.
And if there's a disproportionate amount of people that are doing that,
that happened to be white males that,
you know,
we should probably try to figure out why.
But the idea that you have to force people to hire Asian folks or black folks or
women or whatever,
that's fine.
That seems so crazy to me.
Yes.
Serve the story.
Right.
And to give you a little glimpse that it's,
to give you some context with what might be going on in gaming,
there was this very popular game series called the Witcher,
which is made by a Polish developer called CD project there in Warsaw.
And it's based on the fusion of like Polish kind of identity with this famous
book series that's based on like kind of Polish or you know,
like kind of the Lord of the rings,
but in Eastern Europe.
And One guy's cartoon character that works at this website called Polygon in his
review was talking about how uh,
there were no,
there was no diversity there.
And,
and,
and everyone's like,
dude,
it's Poland and it's based on Poland of your right.
And it's about dragons and like goblins and there's some white guys and this is
like what you're upset about,
you know,
and there's another guy making,
and I think he's Slovakia and I don't want to,
somewhere in eastern Europe making a game called kingdom come deliverance.
And it's supposed to be very realistic.
Look at something like the 14th or 15th century in that area.
And again,
the,
they're complaining,
there's no diversity,
there's no diversity.
And he's like,
there was no black people in this area in 1500 I'm trying to make a game that's
true to the air does that,
that doesn't make him a racist.
And,
and these are the kinds of,
this is just the kind of bullshit,
but you see this in movies,
you see this in TV shows.
It's not,
it's not exclusive,
the gaming,
but it's,
but it's what I've had to deal with for a long time.
And I'm just saying it's the root of it.
The what?
What's causing it,
like why,
why do people feel like they have to put a black person and a game about Poland
and the 15 hundreds or whatever it was?
I think,
I mean,
I don't the,
thankfully the people that make the games don't care.
They're like,
we're going to make our game.
Right.
The people that are complaining about it,
they're virtuous virtue signaling,
which is not even a term.
I even knew what it meant until a few weeks ago.
Like I heard people throw that term around.
I didn't quite know what a man I looked at.
I looked into it.
It's,
you know,
and you know what it is.
It's,
it's the idea that these virtuous people,
at the same people that attack me for the joke,
I have to virtuous and show that I am against sexism.
So I have to attack the man.
You know,
I have to do all these kinds of things in this need,
you know?
But what they're saying,
when they,
when they're saying we have to have,
um,
black people in this game,
in eastern Europe,
in the 15 hundreds,
what they're saying,
what they're really saying is you're a racist.
Yeah.
That's the,
that's the subtext.
And it goes back to this character assassination in this need to destroy.